y las fórmulas de cinemática rotacional
nos permiten relacionar las cinco
variables diferentes del movimiento
rotacional que son como las fórmulas que
normalmente se aplican en cinemática
excepto que en lugar de desplazamiento
tenemos desplazamiento angular en lugar
de velocidad inicial tenemos velocidad
angular inicial en lugar de velocidad
final tenemos velocidad angular final y
en lugar de aceleración tenemos
aceleración angular y bueno el tiempo
sigue siendo el tiempo ahora para un
examen como este solo necesitamos las
primeras dos fórmulas la 3 y la 4
generalmente no se necesitan y estas
fórmulas solo son verdaderas si la
aceleración angular es constante pero
qué significa cada una de las variables
bueno el desplazamiento angular es la
distancia en grados que un objeto gira
en un cierto tiempo t y la velocidad
angular se define como la rotación en
grados /
el tiempo justo como la velocidad es
igual al desplazamiento entre el tiempo
y la aceleración angular se define como
el cambio de la velocidad angular entre
el tiempo justo como la aceleración
normal es igual al cambio de la
velocidad entre el tiempo y para algo
que gira describiendo un círculo los
puntos de la velocidad angular son
perpendiculares al plano de rotación
pero es más fácil decir si omega va en
el sentido de las manecillas del reloj o
en el sentido contrario y mire para
obtener la longitud de arco s que el
objeto ha recorrido simplemente
multiplicamos el radio por el
desplazamiento angular y para calcular
la velocidad del objeto multiplicamos el
radio por la velocidad angular y para
calcular la aceleración tangencial
multiplicamos el radio por la
aceleración angular ahora observen que
esta es la aceleración tangencial que
causa que el objeto acelere y desacelere
y la aceleración centrípeta
para que el objeto cambie de dirección
la fórmula para eso es v cuadrada entre
er entonces los objetos que se mueven en
una trayectoria curvilínea tienen que
tener una aceleración centrípeta porque
cambian de dirección pero solo si
aceleran o desacelerar tendremos
aceleración tangencial y aceleración
angular veamos un ejemplo supongamos que
un objeto gira describiendo un círculo a
una velocidad constante cuál de las
siguientes respuestas describe mejor las
aceleraciones del objeto los tres tipos
de aceleraciones del objeto bueno si un
objeto se mueve describiendo un círculo
tiene que haber aceleración centrípeta
por lo tanto será diferente de cero y si
está rotando a una velocidad constante
entonces no hay cambio en omega eso
significa que la aceleración angular es
igual a cero y si la aceleración angular
es igual a cero la aceleración
tangencial también
será igual a 0 porque únicamente cuando
el objeto acelera o desacelera
existe una aceleración angular y
tangencial esto cambia la velocidad y la
aceleración centrípeta cambia la
dirección ahora que significa torca
bueno la torca es la fuerza causante de
la aceleración angular y para que el
movimiento angular de un objeto acelere
y desacelere tiene que existir una torca
neta y para eso se necesitan fuerzas
entonces para que exista una torca
tenemos que tener una fuerza y cada
fuerza puede ejercer una tuerca
diferente dependiendo de en donde se
aplica min si las fuerzas se aplican
lejos del eje de rotación
tendremos una torca mayor en comparación
con cuando se aplica una fuerza cerca
del eje de rotación y eso es lo que
representa esta r&r nos dice que tan
lejos del eje se aplica la fuerza y para
incrementar esa fuerza se debe aplicar
perpendicular r
ya que el seno de 90 grados es igual a 1
entonces para incrementar la torca
debemos aplicar una fuerza perpendicular
a r lo más lejos posible del eje de
rotación y puede que tengamos muchos
ángulos en un problema pero este ángulo
siempre será el ángulo entre r y f y de
forma similar a un objeto que se
encuentra en equilibrio traslacional la
fuerza neta es igual a cero entonces
podemos decir que cuando un objeto se
encuentra en equilibrio rotacional la
torca neta es igual a cero con lo que la
aceleración angular también es igual a
cero justo como el equilibrio
traslacional provoca que la aceleración
sea igual a cero ahora la torca es un
vector tiene una dirección y
generalmente es lógico pensar en que la
dirección va en el sentido contrario o
en el mismo sentido al de las manecillas
del reloj dependiendo de hacia donde se
aplique la fuerza para que el objeto
rote y como la torca es igual
por efe la unidad nos queda como metros
por newton o newton metro veamos un
ejemplo supongamos que tenemos esta
barra con este eje y se aplican
diferentes fuerzas como se muestra en la
imagen queremos saber qué tan grande
debe ser la fuerza a efe para que la
barra se encuentre en equilibrio y
rotacional recuerden equilibrio
rotacional significa que la torca neta
es igual a cero es decir que toda la
torca que se encuentre hacia el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj tiene que
ser igual a la torca que se encuentre
hacia el sentido contrario de las
manecillas del reloj para que el sistema
esté en equilibrio entonces las fuerzas
de 1 y 3 newtons están tratando de hacer
que el sistema gire en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj pero la fuerza
desconocida a efe trata de hacer que el
sistema rote en el sentido contrario y
la fuerza de color verde en realidad no
está aplicando ninguna torca porque aun
cuando r no
es igual a 0 el ángulo entre la fuerza y
el valor de r es igual a 180 grados y el
seno de 180 grados es igual a 0 lo cual
tiene sentido porque esta fuerza en
realidad no provoca que la barra rote
entonces la torca en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj es igual a un metro
por 3 newtons en el caso de la torca de
3 newtons más ojo no son 2 metros para
la fuerza de un newton acuérdense que
siempre debemos partir del eje de
rotación así que tenemos tres metros por
un newton entonces la torca en el
sentido de las manecillas del reloj es
igual a 6 newtons por metro y ahora
vamos a escribir la torca aplicada por
la fuerza desconocida a efe como un
metro por efe así que para que 6 newtons
por metro sea igual a 1 por efe la
fuerza f es igual a 6 newtons
qué es la inercia rotacional bueno a un
objeto con una inercia rotacional grande
será difícil hacerlo girar así como
detenerlo así que la inercia rotacional
nos dice que tanto se resistirá un
objeto a la aceleración angular justo
como la inercia nos dice que tanto se
resistirá un objeto a la aceleración y
bueno la inercia rotacional se refiere
al momento de inercia pero como hacemos
que la inercia rotacional sea grande
bueno eso lo podemos hacer si colocamos
la masa lejos del eje de rotación y por
el contrario para que la inercia
rotacional sea pequeña simplemente
podemos colocar la masa cerca del eje de
rotación es decir que si empujamos una
masa cerca del eje de rotación que es el
punto en el que el objeto rota podemos
hacer que el momento de inercia sea más
pequeño
y para encontrar el momento de inercia o
la inercia rotacional de un objeto cuya
masa gira con el mismo radio r podemos
usar la fórmula y es igual a m la masa
que está girando por la distancia a la
que se encuentra del eje al cuadrado y
esta es una fórmula que tienen que
memorizar y es igual a m por r al
cuadrado y por ejemplo si tenemos muchas
masas girando a diferentes eres
simplemente sumamos la contribución de
cada una
ahora si tenemos una masa continua las
fórmulas son un poco más complicadas por
ejemplo para una barra giratoria cuyo
eje se localiza en el centro de la barra
el momento de inercia es igual a un
doceavo por la masa de la barra por la
longitud total de la barra al cuadrado y
para una barra cuyo eje de rotación se
encuentra en un extremo el momento de
inercia es mayor ya que existe más masa
distribuida lejos del eje y esta fórmula
es
a un tercio de la masa de la barra por
la longitud total de la barra al
cuadrado
ahora la inercia rotacional de una
esfera cuyo eje de rotación pasa por el
centro es igual a dos quintos por la
masa de la esfera por el radio de la
esfera al cuadrado y la inercia
rotacional de un cilindro o de un disco
cuyo eje de rotación pasa por el centro
es igual a un medio de la masa por el
radio al cuadrado y bueno otro ejemplo
que es muy común y que no les dan la
fórmula en un examen es un aro observen
que aquí toda la masa está distribuida
alrededor de un centro que está hueco y
como toda la masa se encuentra al mismo
radio r la fórmula para la inercia
rotacional de un aro es la misma que
aplicamos para la inercia rotacional de
una masa que gira alrededor de un eje
con el mismo radio r porque el hecho de
que la masa esté distribuida en un
círculo no tiene importancia pues
massa siempre se encuentra en el mismo
radio y bueno como la inercia rotacional
no es un vector siempre será positiva o
igual a cero y para las unidades como
estamos multiplicando m por r al
cuadrado entonces tenemos kilogramos por
metro al cuadrado ok veamos un ejemplo
supongamos que dos cilindros ruedan
colina abajo desde el reposo sin
deslizarse la masa del cilindro a está
distribuida igualmente por todo el
cilindro pero el cilindro b está hecho
de un material más denso y tiene un
hueco en el centro con la masa
distribuida alrededor del eje si las
masas y el radio de los cilindros son
iguales que cilindros llegará primero al
final de la colina bueno para saber que
el cilindro llega primero necesitamos
preguntarnos cuál rodará más fácilmente
claro al cilindro con el momento de
inercia menor le será más fácil girar
eso significa que rodará fácil
y llegará al final de la colina más
rápido pero si tenemos una masa que está
distribuida lo más lejos posible del eje
de rotación esos objetos tendrán el
momento de inercia más grande y miren
como la masa del cilindro p se encuentra
más lejos del eje
a diferencia del cilindro a el cilindro
b tendrá un momento de inercia mayor
será más difícil que gire y se tardará
más tiempo en bajar la colina
por lo tanto ganará el cilindro a cuál
es la versión angular de la segunda ley
de newton la segunda ley de newton dice
que la aceleración es igual a la fuerza
neta entre la masa así que la versión
angular de la segunda ley de newton dice
que la aceleración angular es igual a la
torca neta entre la inercia rotacional y
miren m nos dice que tanto se resiste un
objeto a la aceleración mientras que la
inercia rotacional nos indica que tanto
se resiste un objeto a la aceleración
angular
entonces es como cuando sumamos los
vectores de fuerza tenemos que tener
cuidado con los signos lo mismo se
aplica con la torca la torca es un
vector así que puede ser positiva si va
en el sentido de las manecillas del
reloj o negativa si va en el sentido
contrario veamos un ejemplo supongamos
que la barra que se muestra abajo tiene
una inercia rotacional de dos kilogramos
por metro cuadrado y las fuerzas actúan
como se muestra nosotros queremos saber
cuál es la magnitud de la aceleración
angular de la barra entonces vamos a
usar la segunda ley de newton en su
forma angular que dice que la
aceleración angular es igual a la torca
neta entre la inercia rotacional y como
ya tenemos la inercia rotacional sólo
necesitamos la torca neta y para eso
necesitamos calcular la torca de cada
una de estas fuerzas vamos a ver la
torca de la fuerza de un newton es r que
en este caso está a 3 metros del eje
por la fuerza que es de un newton y como
esta fuerza se aplica perpendicularmente
a r el seno de 90 grados es igual a 1
así que la torca de la fuerza de un
newton es igual a 3 newtons por metro en
dirección contraria al sentido de las
manecillas del reloj y la torca en el
caso de la fuerza de 4 newtons sería un
metro porque se aplica a un metro del
eje por 4 newtons y eso es igual a 4
newtons por metro en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj así que la torca
neta es igual a 4 newtons por metro en
el sentido de las manecillas del reloj y
3 newtons por metro en el sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj por
lo tanto la torca neta es igual a un
newton por metro en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj porque 4 es una
unidad más grande que 3 y esto lo
dividimos entre la inercia rotacional
que es
2 entonces la aceleración angular es
igual a 0.5 y que es la energía cinética
rotacional bueno si un objeto está
girando tiene una energía cinética
rotacional y si el centro de la masa del
objeto se mueve y el objeto está girando
decimos que tiene una energía cinética
traslacional normal y una energía
cinética rotacional las dos son energía
cinética y esta es sólo una forma de
diferenciar los dos tipos así podemos
calcular la energía cinética total de
algo que se mueve y gira al mismo tiempo
entonces la fórmula para la energía
cinética rotacional es igual a un medio
por la inercia rotacional por la
velocidad angular al cuadrado lo cual
tiene sentido porque la fórmula que
todos conocemos para calcular la energía
cinética es igual a un medio por la masa
por la velocidad al cuadrado entonces si
uno
objeto está girando tiene una energía
cinética rotacional pero si el centro de
la masa de un objeto se está moviendo
entonces tiene una energía cinética de
traslación y si el centro de la masa se
mueve y al mismo tiempo el objeto gira
entonces decimos que el objeto tiene
tanto energía rotacional como energía
traslacional ahora la energía cinética
rotacional no es un vector siempre será
positiva o igual a cero y las unidades
son kilogramos por metro al cuadrado
entre segundo al cuadrado y como estamos
hablando de energía esto es igual a
jules veamos un ejemplo una torca
constante es aplicada sobre un cilindro
que inicialmente se encontraba en reposo
y que puede rotar mediante un eje que
pasa por su centro cuál de estas curvas
demuestra la mejor energía cinética
rotacional del cilindro en función del
tiempo bueno si se aplica una tuerca
constante sobre
un objeto entonces la aceleración
angular también es constante y si la
aceleración angular es constante
podemos usar las fórmulas cinéticas para
calcular la velocidad final de este
objeto miren la velocidad angular final
como el objeto empieza desde el reposo
es igual a alfa por t y eso significa
que la energía cinética rotacional de
este objeto se puede escribir como un
medio por el momento de inercia que es
una constante por omega al cuadrado y en
este caso nos queda como un medio por y
por alfa t al cuadrado entonces como la
función de la energía cinética es
proporcional al tiempo al cuadrado si
gráfica mos la energía cinética en
función del tiempo obtenemos una
parábola así que la respuesta correcta
es la opción b
que es el momento angular bueno la razón
por la que nos interesa el momento
angular es porque será conservado por un
sistema si no hay una tuerca externa en
el sistema y esto es justo como en el
momento normal en el que tenemos masa
por velocidad solo que el momento
angular es igual a la inercia rotacional
por la velocidad angular y esta es una
fórmula muy buena para calcular el
momento angular de un objeto extendido
cuya masa se encuentra distribuida en
diferentes puntos alejados del eje de
rotación pero los raros sobre el momento
angular es que aún cuando una masa
puntual se mueve en línea recta puede
tener momento angular y para calcular el
momento angular de una masa puntual que
se mueve en línea recta
simplemente multiplicamos la masa del
objeto por la velocidad de ese objeto y
ya sea que lo multipliquen por qué tan
lejos se encuentra del eje por el seno
del ángulo que hay entre el vector
la velocidad y erre o también una forma
más sencilla es simplemente multiplicar
por la distancia más cercana es decir
que tan cerca ha estado esa masa del eje
así que para calcular el momento angular
de esta masa que se mueve en línea recta
pueden dibujar una línea recta para
indicar su trayectoria y observen qué
tan cerca ha estado o podría estar del
eje eso es ser mayúscula y si
multiplican eso por la masa y por la
velocidad pueden calcular el momento
angular de esa masa puntual ahora el
momento angular es un vector y es más
fácil pensar en la dirección del momento
angular como en el sentido contrario a
las manecillas del reloj o en el sentido
de las manecillas del reloj dependiendo
de hacia donde esté girando el objeto y
para las unidades si multiplicamos masa
kilogramos por metros entre segundo por
metros
that para el momento angular nos queda
como kilogramos por metro cuadrado entre
segundo veamos un ejemplo supongamos que
una esfera de arcilla de masa m se
dirige hacia una barra que tiene una
masa 3 m y una longitud l con una
velocidad b y la barra puede girar
libremente alrededor del eje que se
encuentra en uno de sus extremos si la
arcilla se pega al final de la barra
cuál será la velocidad angular de la
barra después de que la arcilla se pegue
y nos dicen que el momento de inercia de
una barra que gira alrededor de uno de
sus extremos es un tercio ml al cuadrado
ok bueno como en este sistema no hay
torca neta externa el momento angular
del sistema será conservado y el único
objeto que inicialmente tiene un momento
angular es la esfera de arcilla entonces
como tenemos una masa puntual moviéndose
en línea recta usa
la fórmula m por la velocidad por lo más
cerca que nos encontramos del eje que es
el la longitud de la bar y eso es igual
al momento angular final que lo podemos
escribir como y por omega y miren esta y
será el momento de inercia tanto de la
barra como de la arcilla pegada al final
de la barra entonces tenemos m de l es
igual al momento total de inercia y
sabemos que el momento de inercia de la
barra es un tercio por la masa de la
barra que es 13 m por la longitud de la
barra al cuadrado más el momento de
inercia de la arcilla pegada al final de
la barra que es igual a la masa de la
arcilla por el radio del círculo que
traza la arcilla que es la longitud del
abarth entonces estamos usando la
fórmula para el momento de inercia de
una masa puntual en donde toda la masa
está girando al mismo radio del centro y
eso lo sumamos
momento de inercia de la barra y lo
multiplicamos por omega ok así el
término entre corchetes nos queda como 2
ml al cuadrado y podemos cancelar las
semis también podemos cancelar una de
las teles y nos queda que omega es igual
a v entre 2 l finalmente me gustaría
hablar de una fórmula más general para
la energía potencial gravitacional pero
para que necesitamos una fórmula más
general bueno si están en una región en
donde el campo gravitacional g minúscula
es constante entonces podemos usar la
fórmula m por g por h para encontrar la
energía potencial gravitacional pero si
están en una región en donde el campo
gravitacional es variable entonces
tenemos que usar esta fórmula más
general que establece que la energía
potencial gravitacional entre dos masas
m1 y m2 sera
igual a menos la constante de
gravitación g mayúscula por el producto
de las dos masas entre la distancia que
hay de centro a centro entre las dos
masas ojo observen que esta es una
distancia del centro al centro no de
superficie superficie y no está elevada
al cuadrado como en la fórmula de fuerza
ésta es sólo la distancia ahora la
energía potencial gravitacional no es un
vector pero por este signo negativo
siempre será negativa o igual a cero y
solo será cero cuando estas masas estén
infinitamente alejadas porque si
dividimos algo entre infinito por
ejemplo uno entre infinito es igual a
cero y si no es cero siempre será
negativa pero aún cuando la energía
potencial gravitacional sea negativa
esta energía aún puede ser convertida en
energía cinética solo que para que la
energía potencial gravitacional
disminuya tendrá que ser aún
negativa para poder convertir esa
energía en energía cinética saque el
tema en esta sección porque como los
planetas están orbitando tenemos que
usar esta fórmula para determinar la
energía potencial gravitacional entre
ellos y como esa energía las unidades
serán just veamos un ejemplo supongamos
que tenemos dos esferas de radio r y de
masa m que se sienten atraídas por su
atracción gravitacional si la distancia
entre ellas de superficie a superficie
empieza siendo de 4 r y termina de 12 r
cuánta energía cinética ganará el
sistema bueno como necesitamos incluir
las dos masas en nuestro sistema eso
significa que no hay trabajo externo así
que la energía del sistema se conserva
el sistema empieza con una energía
potencial gravitacional entonces menos g
mayúscula por las dos masas que como se
multiplican las podemos escribir como
al cuadrado entre la distancia inicial
que no es 4 r porque recuerden que debe
de ser la distancia de centro a centro
entonces sería 6 r y suponiendo que
empezamos desde el reposo al inicio no
hay energía cinética y esto es igual a
la energía potencial gravitacional final
g mayúscula por la masa al cuadrado
entre la distancia final que de centro
al centro es 4 r más la energía
potencial que haya sido convertida a
energía cinética entonces despejando a
la energía cinética nos queda menos g
mayúscula por m al cuadrado entre 6 r
más g mayúscula por m al cuadrado entre
4 r y un cuarto menos un sexto es igual
a un doceavo así que la cantidad de
energía potencial que se convierte en
energía cinética es g mayúscula por m al
cuadrado entre 12 r